the Apollo 3500 GT is a sports car with
southern flair his lines were inspired
by the iconic cars of its age such as
the Jaguar e-type and in particular the
stunningly beautiful Ferraris designed
by Pininfarina physicians this
enthusiast says the Apollo is a kind of
American Ferrari and very rare
the Apollo 3500 GT was intended to
provide an alternative to European
sports cars which were often very costly
to maintain this American Ferrari was
also powered by an American engine a v8
it's three and a half liters of cubic
capacity produced a sporty sound and
more than enough propulsion for the
lightweight Apollo which weighed just a
thousand kilos and fourth gear the 200
horsepower GT could hit a top speed of
210 kilometers an hour a pretty
respectable pace back in the early 1960s
ugliest glove says the goal was to
create America's answer to the Ferrari
using American technology and an Italian
body for the engine they chose a newly
developed v8 from GM's Buick Motor
Division the three and a half liter all
aluminum engine was very light perfect
for a sports car
this engine went on to enjoy great
success as the rover v8 in various
models including the Range Rover the
Morgan +8 and the TVR 350 I
in spite of its mass-produced American
technology the Apollo can go like the
wind the engine sits far behind the rear
axle and ensures even weight
distribution no front heavy American
Cruiser the Apollo is an agile and
speedy Gran Turismo that's fun to drive
the Apollo's contours are inspired by
Italian design though it's anything but
a Ferrari ripoff its design is unique
even if it doesn't dump many details
used in Ferrari models in the 1960s but
that's little wonder
because today his cough explains that
the body was made in Italy and the
designer was Italian franco Scaglione
had worked for Ferrari and got Tony
before the car bodies were shipped to
the US but the cost got a way out of
hand
so just 70 odd Apollo's were produced
over the course of six years 40 are
thought to be still in existence today
I'm glad I've spent years looking for
his apollo during this time he became
somewhat of a specialist on the sports
car and advises apollo fans and owners
around the globe
the technician off says the cars
technology is affordable he says all the
parts are available as long as you know
what car they came from he says that the
tough but special thing is the body
which was handmade by intimate Connie
Collins the first two cars were made of
aluminum but then they realized that
cost too much after that the cars were
made from steel with aluminum hoods
trunk lids and doors he says it's an
American forerunner II and very rare
anomaly counterfeit one exclaims I
didn't notice with the help of experts
in five years of hard work Goff
completely rebuilt his Apollo he now
owns a second Apollo a 5000 GT with the
larger engine that was installed later
it's another restoration project finding
the right internal parts hasn't been a
problem but replacing missing or damaged
parts of the bodywork is far from easy
handwork and improvisation are the order
of the day bref says that in such a case
you must make everything yourself
he needed a rocker panel as they're very
prone to rust in these cars so he had to
produce one from scratch himself at the
front here he had to install a part two
which he made himself because no
replacements exist plank the Ferraris of
its day the Apollo's body was completely
handmade the traces of this are still
visible in the sheet metal today
Graf says you can still see the hammer
blows on the bodywork and that even when
you're restoring it you can't be too
exacting you can really see the
difference compared with factory
produced or machine made bodies but he
says that's how things were at that time
he points out a spot where you can see
how the parts were put together and
notes this is a thing of the past
that's how my hard-to-reach man in doubt
on buzzer
in the end the apollo proved too costly
to make and production ended in 1968 but
on glass cloth still enjoys taking his
out for a spin
although the paolo isn't yet a
high-priced collector's item prices for
these rare models have risen
considerably in recent years